tous les matins à 8h30 elle va prendre
son boulot peep show elle s'appelle
nelly rue saint denis
[Musique]
mais ce but
quant à face dans la rue les gens se
disent
je
de vivre avec un brockman toujours
branché mari elle s'en fout
son père lui dit que c'est un garçon
manqué et puis ça la faisait bloc
maintenant elle tend smart
c
et avant cela
rire danser
[Musique]
donc ça
c'est complexe sonné
[Musique]
zik sont fumées
clinton
six heures du soir est tout autre chez
elle sa chambre c'est son septième en
mai lire d'abord un sujet qui a une
telle vie quotidienne on a même vu
comment tu arrivé le matin henri
horaires tu viens d'où je viens des
nations je t'avais qu'à leurs huit
heures du matin 8h du matin le coeur tu
commences ça dure jusqu'à quelle heure
00h30 muette douilles de 9 heures du
matin venu y voilà c'est incroyable ça
reprend beaucoup d'heures assez
imposante énormément d'heures
tu fais ça quand même jour par semaine
six jours par semaine six jours par
soignants et longtemps que tu fais ça
trois ans
trois entreprises avant avant j'étais
secrétaire
ce facteur voilà un jour de plus l'arrêt
de ses créateurs voilà exactement tout
est secrétaire de qui enfin sans donner
de noms mais dans une société de quoi tu
peux dire même si tu cite pas de noms
dans une usine de fromagerie ouais t'as
eu assez et est venue la tête rapporte
beaucoup d'argent de faire ça assez
combien le comme une secrétaire de
direction
certes est devenu ce que ça marche je
travaille autant vitrolles je n'étais
pas secrétaire de direction mais là tu
es arrivé au salaire de sénateur de
douala et l'ordi dans les mecs tu les
vois l'équipe qui m comment il met m 10
francs commune
tout dépend
tu dépenses pour arié entre 20 francs
130 mm 100 française de 10 francs en
pièces de 10 francs toujours tu les vois
toi pas du tout je sais pas question dès
votre centre je sais comme il y en a au
tour quand même tu peux découvrir comme
il y en a oui parce que d'un petit
voyant il ya un petit sur la piste oui
donc voici quelqu'un à cannes où il
reste combien de temps et il y en a
classé la journée toute la journée
peut-être pas mais pas mal d'heures oui
pas mal de verre doit magasin pas mal
d'heures ils descendirent monte
voilà et tu sens que les habitués tu
sais qu'il ya des habitués ou non au oui
oui et beaucoup de gens qui reviennent
ou les et toi quand tu fais ça tu te
fais du bien tu fais semblant vite
arrive de faire du bien quand même
bien sûr j'aime ça des fois ça te plaît
de le faire sans clé et c'est excitant
de savoir qu'il ya plein de mecs qui te
regardent en train de faire ça tout de
suite d'une certaine manière oui oui
vous cette excite beaucoup c'est juste
un peu c'est excite pas plus qui est
seul avec un mec qui n'ont quand même
pas était déjà essayé avec des objets
par exemple j'ai pas des fous et des
gosses des trucs non pourquoi
c'est interdit par la direction non non
non ce n'est pas interdit par la
direction maman tu dépends pas envie
j'ai pas envie dont je dis c'est que tu
fais ça bien sûr
qu'est ce qu'il dit mais il a bien pris
il a bien accepté
c'était déjà tangible quand était
secrétaire oui il t'a vu passer du
secrétariat au strip tease est sûre mais
pourquoi il est d'accord ce que je les
étudiants et c'est moi qui lui paye ses
études
donc il y voit un intérêt voilà ça
m'embête pas non si on met pas du tout
les soirs quand tu arrives à la maison
tu veux en avoir marre un petit peu
m'enfin on fait aller ça se sent pas
dans vos relations
non pas du tout pas lutter je t'arrête
combien de mois par an un mois un mois
par an pas moi pas m'en étais parents
ils savent que tu fais ça bien sûr
disent rien
c'est à dire qu'ils ont mal accepté dès
le départ je l'aurais je leur ai dit
petit à petit et je l'aurais fait mais à
prendre ceux ci étaient amis le savent
quelques amis quelques amis le savent
les mois qui viennent te voir des femmes
des gens que tu connais ce n'est pas
encore arrivé c'est peut-être mérité de
suite en effet aperçu il l'aurait dit tu
penses je pense qu'il me l'aurait dit
oui mais tu as envie de faire ça pendant
combien de temps encore quelques années
je pense qu'il définit ses études voilà
jusqu à ce qu il a un travail et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de winne a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux